في مركز القيادة بالقاهرة
السلطات المصرية تعمل على
مدار الساعة وزير الصحة المصري على أهبة الاستعداد لاستقبال
بعض المرضى الأكثر ضعفًا
ويتوقع دخول أكثر من 30 طفلًا حديث الولادة إلى
مصر جديدًا على العالم
ولكنهم وقعوا في مرمى النيران بينما يبدأ الجيش الإسرائيلي
غارته في الداخل  يعد وقت مستشفى ألفا
مهمًا وكل
دقيقة لا نصل إليها، فإن
الحوادث أو
فرص فقدان حياتهم
مرتفعة جدًا منذ الأول من نوفمبر، حيث
عبر الفلسطينيون المصابون عبر
الحدود الأكثر وعورة إلى مصر
شريان الحياة الوحيد  لمغادرة غزة خصصنا 37
مستشفى بها أكثر من 11000 سرير
لهذا الغرض وأكثر من 700 وحدة للعناية المركزة
مع أه حاضنات
للأطفال ومرافق أخرى
لغسيل الكلى وما إلى ذلك هل يمكنك
القول أن عدد الجرحى
الفلسطينيين الذي  موجودون في مصر الآن
بالمئات يقتربون من أكثر من
200 في جولة حصرية يأخذنا فيها الوزير جعفر
لزيارة المرضى، هذا هو البطل، هذا
هو عبد هنا في
معهد ناسا الطبي في القاهرة، أخيرًا آمنون
ولكن يطاردهم ما جلبهم إلى هنا من
حسرة الذنب  اليأس المطلق يلوم محمد وديع
نفسه على
إصابات أطفاله، ويقول إنه استمع إلى
تحذير جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي وانتقل جنوبًا من
الشمال فقط ليكون جزءًا من غارة جوية
على خان يونس في
16 أكتوبر، وذهب لشراء الطعام وعندما
عاد كان كل شيء على ما يرام.  ذهب يخبرني أن
ابنه عبد الرحمن يبلغ من العمر 9 سنوات فقط
ويقاتل من خلال سبع إصابات حربية وأن
أخته البالغة من العمر 14 عامًا بجانبه أصيبت
بشظايا في أجسادهما الصغيرة وكسور في
العظام بالنسبة لي أنا
استشاري جراحة العظام واستشاري جراحة العظام
وغيرها  كان الفريق بلاستيكيًا يقولون إنه لا توجد
جروح جسدية يمكن مقارنتها
بالندوب العقلية، هل يمكنك أن تتخيل
طفلًا لديك طفل وهو خائف ولا ينبغي أن
يخاف من قطة أو كلب داكن لذا أه
عندما تجد ذلك خائفًا من
فقدان بالم لعائلته  إنه أمر
صادم حقًا، هل تلقيت تحذيرًا، هل
اتصل
بك شخص ما، أخبرني لا، لا تحذير بشأن
معرفته بحماس في مبناه،
يقول لا، سنلتقي بالعائلة التالية
ويتذكرون هذه
الضربة 2: مساءً.  31 أكتوبر
مخيم جباليا ماجد كانت تصلي عندما
خرج زوجها رامي محمود لإحضار الطعام
وعندما عاد إلى منزله
وجد إلهام من خلال رؤية إصبع واحد يخرج
من تحت الأنقاض
نجت ولكن اثنين من أطفالها
لم ينقذوها 15-  اتصلت ابنة تبلغ من العمر عامًا
بصديقتها قبل وفاتها وتنبأت بأن
شيئًا ما سيحدث لها، وأظهر
لي رامي مقطع فيديو لابنه الذي قام بقص شعره
قبل 3 أيام من الضربة، وأخبروني أنه
يريد أن يبدو جيدًا إذا
مات قليلاً مقابل كل ما التقينا به.  أمنية واحدة
تلزمهم جميعًا بالعودة إلى ديارهم في
غزة